VIC FRYZEL: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Vic Fryzel, and this
is Nicolas Garnier.
Today, we're going to be talking
about the Google Drive
SDK and a new way to install
your application, which we
call the Install Scope.
So just to give some background,
when we first
launched the Google Drive SDK,
you had to install your
application using the Chrome
Web Store, and installation
was required for an application
or to do anything
with the Drive API.
We've gotten a lot of feedback
about that, and we've since
changed things a little bit.
So no longer is installation
required for your app to work
with the Drive API.
It's just required for your app
to show up in the Google
Drive user interface.
And we've also changed the
installation mechanism a
little bit.
So you can still install your
application from the Chrome
Web Store, but we've added
a new way for you to
install your apps.
So the Install Scope is
essentially an OAuth 2.0 scope
that you add when requesting
an OAuth token.
And if this token is granted to
your application, if this
token is approved by the user,
then your application is
automatically installed
into the
Google Drive user interface.
So this is kind of an important
distinction, because
previously, a user would have to
go to the Chrome Web Store
and click Add to Drive to
install the application, but
that's no longer the case.
So this allows installation
of Drive applications from
outside of the Chrome Web
Store, maybe in your own
application, for instance.
So today, what we're going to
do is go through how to use
this scope, and we're going to
show you how an application
gets installed into Drive.
NICOLAS GARNIER: With
the new scope.
So what would we like
to start with?
VIC FRYZEL: Maybe we'll go
through the documentation.
NICOLAS GARNIER: All right.
So this is the documentation.
I hope you guys can see
that on the screen.
The new Install scope here,
which I'm highlighting and--
which I'm trying
to highlight--
sorry.
And guys, if you're familiar
with OAuth 2, you need to send
user to the grant screen.
And on the grant screen,
you'll get a message,
depending on which scopes
you are trying to
get the user to approve.
And for that particular scope
here, which we call the
drive.install scope, this whole
scope, you'll get this
little message, which basically
says My App.
It should be the name of your
application right there.
My App is requesting permission
to add itself to
Google Drive and appear
basically in the Google Drive
Open With menu and appear in the
Google Drive Create menu.
So this is basically going to
enable your app to appear on
the user's menu inside Google
Drive, which I can
show you right now.
I have a few applications
installed.
So this is my Drive, and as you
can see here on the Create
under More, I have a bunch of
third-party applications that
I have installed already, like
Balsamiq, like Pixel Editor,
[INAUDIBLE]
Chart, et cetera.
And also, if I, I think,
right-click on the file--
and here I haven't
right clicked.
I left-clicked instead.
In our Open With, for example,
here, I can with HelloFax open
the Google document, and
also with [INAUDIBLE]
Writer.
So enabling the Install Scope is
basically going to add your
application there, basically,
on your Google Drive.
You integrate your application
inside the Google
Drive UI of the user.
Do you think we should demo
that with the OAuth 2
Playground?
VIC FRYZEL: Sure.
That sounds like a good idea.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So I don't
know if you guys know the
OAuth 2 Playground.
The OAuth 2 Playground is a tool
that lets you basically
play with the OAuth 2 protocol
and use the APIs, mostly
Google APIs.
I mean, we make it easy for
Google APIs also to work with
third-party APIs.
So it lets you play around with
APIs and basically with
the OAuth 2 protocol.
So this is the interface of
the OAuth 2 Playground.
As you can see here, you can
manually, basically, enter a
scope that you want
to basically
authorize to OAuth 2.
Since the drive.install scope
is not listed on the default
list that we have here, that
is kind of convenient.
You can simply write it
down on that text box.
VIC FRYZEL: So to be clear, this
is just copied and pasted
from the documentation.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yes,
that's right.
VIC FRYZEL: If you were writing
a real application,
you would request at least all
three of these scopes.
But here we're just requesting
only the Install scope so that
we can demonstrate installation
only.
This token that we get back
actually won't be able to do
anything with the Google Drive
SDK outside of be installed,
and that's significant.
So in a real application, you
would request the other scopes
that we mentioned in
the documentation.
NICOLAS GARNIER: The
drive.install scope only
enables DUI integration.
You'll not get access
to any data.
So it's important to also ask
for access to these other
scopes, like the drive.file
scope or the
Drive wide scope, basically.
So one really interesting
feature about the OAuth 2
Playground is that it's actually
a Google Drive
application.
If you can install the OAuth 2
Playground on your Drive, you
will get an option to open
any file with the OAuth 2
Playground and basically play
around with the API on that
particular file, or also, have
the OAuth 2 Playground under
the Create With menu.
And basically here, if we're
going to authorize the
drive.install scope with the
OAuth 2 Playground, what
that's going to do is that's
going to add the OAuth 2
Playground to my drive,
basically install the OAuth 2
Playground to my drive, so
basically enable the drive UI
integration that the OAUth 2
Playground has implemented.
VIC FRYZEL: So the first thing
Nicolas is going to do is
click authorize APIs,
and this is going to
spawn the OAuth flow.
So when he clicks this, you see
the screen here asking for
the application to add itself to
Google Drive, which is the
exact same screen that's in
the documentation here.
So this is exactly what where
we're about to add.
So when he clicks Allow Access,
we're actually going
to grant the token.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So we get
redirected back to the OAuth 2
Playground, so the redirect
step was the first step of
OAuth 2.0 if you're using the
server side flow and also the
contact flow, actually.
The second step, if you're using
the server side flow, is
to exchange the OAuth
code that we give
you in the URL here.
You can see in the URL when the
user gets redirected to
your application here to the
OAuth 2 Playground, now we
simply have to exchange
that code for tokens.
So I'm simply going to click
that button, and here we go.
So we are getting access tokens
and refresh tokens.
Guys, I invite you to look it
up if you want to learn more
on the OAuth 2.0 protocol,
which is the best way to
authorize to use Drive APIs.
Look it up if you have
more questions.
Here, we're going to basically
focus on what enabling
authorizing the drive.install
scope does to--
I mean, how that adds
the OAuth 2
Playground to your drive.
So all we have to do here
is authorize the scope,
basically, and nothing else.
We can choose the scope and the
token that was granted by
the scope to actually
access any data.
What that does is now if I
go back to my drive and I
refresh, now if I right click
on the file in my Google
Drive, I should have if
everything works right.
See, the OAuth 2 Playground is
now an option, so basically,
the OAuth 2 Playground has been
installed to my drive.
The OAuth 2 Playground's Drive
UI integration has been
enabled on my drive.
That's what authorizing the
drive.install scope did.
And now I can use the OAuth 2
Playground like it was a drive
app and perform operations
on that particular file.
VIC FRYZEL: What's important
to note is the Allow Access
screen that Nicolas just got
was for that one particular
file, because his application
had never opened that one file
before, so we weren't requesting
new access there.
It was just access
to that one file.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Well, since it
was the first time we were
using the OAuth Playground from
the Google Drive UI, you
get that prompt, which you don't
get in subsequent times,
which if we were not using the
OAuth Playground-- we were
using a real application--
you would typically get
that grant screen
only the first time.
And after the user has
authorized access and you've
exchanged the OAuth code for
tokens, the user will not see
that grant screen anymore.
It will simply go through
directly to the application.
So maybe we should talk a little
bit about what that
improves, what was the former
way to install applications.
VIC FRYZEL: So this enables you
to spawn an install flow
from within an application.
Here, the sample application
we're using is the OAuth 2
Playground.
But previously this wasn't
possible, because all
installation had to happen
through the Chrome Web Store.
So, here, let's for instance,
take Lucidchart.
If I come to Lucidchart, and I
click Add to Chrome, and I
click Add, this is actually
installing Lucidchart into
Nicolas' drive, which I think
you had installed twice.
And then if I come back here
to Drive and I refresh, I
should see Create More--
Lucidchart diagram.
So that installation required
you to start with
the Chrome Web Store.
What this new Install scope is
going to allow Lucidchart to
do is put an Install button on
their own page so that if a
user with Google Drive lands at
Lucidchart's website, they
can now allow installation
right from there without
having to redirect the user
through the Chrome Web Store.
So we still recommend that
developers list in the Chrome
Web Store for marketing reasons,
but no longer is this
directly attached
to installation.
So you can still install from
the Chrome Web Store.
I mean, that's fine.
We haven't changed
anything there.
We've just tried to make things
a bit more scalable and
easier for developers.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Yeah, we've
added a feature.
And one particular--
something very interesting here
is that it makes it way
easier for developers to
get started, right?
So in the past, you
had to basically--
to start developing that UI
integration, you had to create
first the Chrome Web Store
listing, maybe your test
Chrome Web Store listing,
which takes a while.
You have to enter a bunch
of images, assets.
You have to prove that you are
the owner of the website on
the Chrome Web Store listing,
and then you would be able, as
a developer, to install your
Chrome Web Store listing
application and start
developing, start building
that drive UI integration
on your router.
Now, by authorizing a simple
scope, which you have to do
anyway-- you have to authorize
the other drive scopes--
you simply get the UI
integration enabled, and you
can start working from there.
It's a really faster way to get
started for developers and
start coding.
VIC FRYZEL: I think it shaved
maybe 10 minutes off of the
time to start coding.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Actually,
even more.
I mean, I've created a bunch of
Chrome Web Store listings.
If you're not used to it and
don't have the proper images
of the exact right pixel size,
it would take maybe half an
hour or something like that
to get started there.
And now we're making
it a lot easier.
In one minute you could even
use the OAuth 2 Playground,
and enter your app's credentials
and the Install
scope, click Install, and,
boom, you will have your
application installed
on your drive UI.
VIC FRYZEL: So a few
other things
about the Install scope.
If Nicolas were to revoke the
token that he granted here,
the application would no longer
be installed in the
Drive User interface.
NICOLAS GARNIER: So revoking
a token, there's a
few ways to do that.
The first way is to go to your
Google Accounts page.
And you have a way to view all
the third-party applications
that have access to
some of your data.
If you revoke the token there
that has the drive that
Install scope authorized for,
basically what that does is
that uninstalls the application
from your Drive UI.
VIC FRYZEL: Also, this allows
third parties to do uninstall.
So, here, a Drive developer
could also send a request to
Google to revoke the token
on the user's behalf.
And given that, the application
would uninstall
itself from Google Drive.
So it's a little bit more
scalable, whereas, otherwise,
the user would have to go into
the Google Drive UI and manage
their applications to
uninstall the app.
So I think we can
show that here.
If I go to Settings, and then
Manage Apps, here are all of
the apps that Nicolas has
installed, and I can remove
any app on here, and
then just click OK.
So that is pretty much it
for the Install scope.
If you have any questions, find
us on Stack Overflow.
You can find the documentation
at developers.googl
e.com/drive/install.
I'm Vic Fryzel.
This is Nicolas Garnier.
Thanks for watching.
NICOLAS GARNIER: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]